so my name is georges papas uh i work at
the university of brasilia and i'm going
to present to you some challenges and
perspectives
of bioinformatics teaching
uh
here in brazil okay so first of all
brazil i'm
really far away from everybody we're
located here in brasilia the capital of
brazil
far away far away from everything
and brasilia
is a nice
city with a very modern architecture so
i'm gonna start
[Music]
like uh
dr rhodes
uh giving you uh my personal experience
uh
in biomathematics
even before bioinformatics was born i'm
not that old but uh
i'm from the 80s
you see
so
the 80s
was really nice and in the 80s i started
programming with
computers so to speak
okay so what we had
uh was
this machine with 16
kb
ram without we didn't have a
monitors we didn't have hard disks
floppy disks anything else
but it was really fun
having us but
being initiated in let's say
computers
even before college okay but in the 80s
there were several things missing
okay
first of all
linux
uh several programming languages that we
use today like python java are
uh
worldwide web we didn't have this we
didn't have cell phones gps
empty phrase and and so and so on
uh but it was really fun
so
uh
moving to the university since computer
science was
such a new film
my other passion was biology and of
course i got a form of education in
molecular biology so
under
at
degrees uh a degree i got at the
university of brasilia and i have
training in all web lab
uh
techniques
uh to characterize biomolecules
any n1 dna
rna proteins okay
and even uh by that time uh i did singer
sequencing by hand
okay running really
big gels like a meter long gels with uh
radio actively
labeled uh ddntps
and
in recollection the wetland was a very
essential experience for me
in my formation
mainly to get uh
the notion of the complexity of
biological systems
okay
so but exactly at that time as you can
see here in 87 i started
programming
and doing research
at lab
that worked with a protein secondary
structure protection
okay based on the amino acid sequences
and by that time i started uh
learning basic
by myself i i learned a c
um and we had
i improved in terms of uh hardware and i
got this computer uh with a
48kb ram
okay
but it was really fun then i i moved to
to
illinois university of illinois at
urbana champaign
where
i exclusively
did work in computational biology
and
uh for that i was working with a brood
instructor
uh
trying to
categorize
uh
structural motifs
and by then
everything was
programming
computers and it was really nice
and
i might
continue biology this is very important
uh
and
in
it was in the 90s and at that time i was
in fact i was one of the first persons
in the world to use a web browser
because it was developed
like next door to me the mosaic web
browser and i recall we had like
at
15
links worldwide and that that was how we
got in terms of websites
and in my uh
evaluation of uh the web browser i said
okay now this won't work
a bad decision uh but okay since last
century i never set foot in a wet lamp
anymore i was strictly a computational
biologist
so in recap what i can say i i i can say
that i have i had a biological
background from theory to practice
and continues
computational to use
in terms of
programming languages
operating seasons
algorithms
but
this is important
no formal academic training it was all
by myself
uh reading through paper books okay
uh
and what happened
in the 80s and 90s in terms of biology
we didn't also have many things such as
automated dna sequencers
economics
a holistic view of biology you see
we had alternatives so gel based summer
sequencing uh genomics was only in
dreams okay
and biology at that time last century uh
wasn't uh
i can say holistic it was
we had an individualized view of uh
individual components oh this protein
this promoter
and that's it and
what we didn't have was this term
bioinformatics
we used to have conventional biology now
we still have computational biology and
everything we did was computational
biology and then of course uh
the genome era in building of biology
began
and it was like uh the big data era of
biology
uh
what happens is that let's say it
started at the end of last century yes
oh you know in 95 with this
first genome published
but
then
in the 21st century
we have
pollution of uh genomics
and uh this is a new trend a new
paradigm for biology itself so
at least to begin with understanding
complex organisms uh
we need to have the
the uh
dna bloop print of the organisms
in order to
try to relate phenotypes with genotypes
and several other
functional aspects of biology and this
is going on okay
so we we even have these uh
very interesting uh project the earth
biogenome product uh in which they want
to
sequence everything in the world and
this will be uh
some
uh very doable
in the next decades okay meaning that we
are gonna have
lots of data let alone the data that we
already have okay so
uh i really like this paper here that i
want to share with you
teresa atwood uh from the beginning
tutorial
uh where
they
say that uh
by mathematics uh is uh immersed in a
feud of high throughput techniques
that generate vast amount of status but
data can only be useful
if
we can turn in
data into knowledge and knowledge into
understanding so
i'm gonna highlight
the key the keywords of what i'm saying
data
knowledge
understanding
okay and
uh of course
what we have is
when
we are in the high throughput not just
genomics all the omex techniques
that generate vast
amount vast amount of
data
of course the new biologists
should
be inserted in this new reality
and
the biologists should be proficient
in doing
some computational analysis
on the other hand we have uh
implementations
exclusively
linked to this field
and
in this case
okay
excel in computational analysis of data
why
we have to turn
uh these uh data analysis uh into
knowledge
but there's a big problem here
there are differences between these two
profiles uh in terms of overall goals
the perspectives of what i can do with
the data
and of course in the training level okay
um
and to turn data into knowledge
okay
this new breed of professionals have to
know algorithms
other areas statistics
aesthetics
as dr rhodes told about how to present
the data oh that's very very important
also but also we need biology and
to transform knowledge into
understanding here comes our focus it's
biology
okay
and
with that
uh i i should quote um
wally gilbert here
uh in in which he says that biologists
must be computer literate
and this is a new paradigm
in the whole biology okay
and in this
uh new biology
uh for the 20th uh
21st century
uh
um
the the author said uh say that uh
he should
the new biologist should not be only uh
a scientist that knows little about
several things
uh we need a deep
knowledge of one discipline let's say
biology one uh one of the biologists
okay uh
we have several biologies
okay and we need work influence
work influencing several
other sub-areas okay
and
what are the challenges of teaching
bioinformatics
so
i i've been teaching bioinformatics
courses
uh
for
20 years for the past 20 years since
2000
2001
and
after two decades
i'm still working on it okay
it's not straightforward
why because it is very difficult to
create and adapt a curriculum that will
feed the needs of all student
aspirations okay this is a
[Music]
there's a big diversity in this aspect
here
and
but anyway
i divided all my courses
based on student background
okay
and
uh
essentially i have courses for
undergraduates graduate students and uh
for students interested in a
bioinformatics career path
so
i organized
the courses
like this with the
uh
for the background
the audience so my audience is biology
and biotechnology majors and in fact
biological sciences even agronomy
uh
some
medical students and so on and so forth
and the objectives here are just to
provide a general introduction of
bioinformatics and bioinformatics tools
and then we have
courses for graduate students
where the objectives are
uh
reflect
the uh students
students seeking proficiency
in doing
in using computational tools to analyze
their data uh
and
the final thing
uh are for research
and of course again for only those who
want to be become uh biofermentations
okay and
so for undergraduate level
it's a single course a 60-hour course
it's a required course uh with a theory
and practice
uh birth semester i have about 40
students
and now
in terms of a graduate courses
i teach multiple courses
multiple
and
i i will get into this later and for
research it's
personal mentoring
so
i was happy to see that iscb
[Music]
developed let's say uh
what a
bioinformatics core competent
uh would be for several levels so
uh they uh had uh competencies for a
bioinformatics user a scientist and an
engineer
and
this is
if
i i don't expect you to read that but
this is exactly what i have here
so
i divide it into tears
so at the undergraduate level the major
focus is given to study biological
databases
okay and
uh why is that in which databases
normal
literature nucleotides proteins
everything related to pro
to proteins in terms of
sequence domains uh enzymes biological
pathways genomes variations and
phenotypes
and uh
data quality assessment
of the databases and of course optimized
preparing the data and of course some
basic tools everything is online here
for for this course okay
and
why
uh
[Music]
uh
basically because of again walter
gilbert
uh when he said oh a new paradigm in
biology
emerged
in that uh biological
uh
and for that the starting point of our
biological investigation will be
theoretical
and with that uh i can present you a
simple let's say simple
in four lines a question uh
that can be asked uh let's say ah how
do i know all the protein coating
genes from dna dna repair system of the
fungus uh c neoformans
this is a very complex biological
question and of course
you can answer
with using bioinformatics tools but just
doing canonical
database surfing and filtering
may not be the the answer uh
you see so uh we have uh some
what i i consider uh optimize
alternatives to using uh
and and pairing that databases and which
it's kind of really simple
uh
okay uh it's stuck here uh just a second
okay i'm not i'm i'm having a problem
with this slide here but
essentially it's gene ontology uh
ensemble and biomart okay uh but here we
go gerontology ensemble and biomart and
we can do this uh uh uh
in less than 15 minutes okay so this is
one of the goals so in terms of uh uh
the overall
appraisal of the students uh
this discipline
has a
very uh good reviews from from the
students uh because they see
bioinformatics
tools as essential
for their careers even
though
they
might not be uh
[Music]
i'm writing one for them
[Music]
but a for
my perspective uh
when they are doing
these studies and uh using the concepts
given with the basic concepts given in
bioinformatics the negative uh aspect is
that i'm kind of i'm having a relatively
low number of students actually engaging
in bioinformatics research
this is low it is low
at the graduate level i i have one
uh
uh
market division of courses
okay so
what happens is that
i teach several
different classes
uh
reaching
ngs
introduction to linux
our programming for bioinformatics
okay
and pipelines for bioinformatics i'm not
going into the uh details here
but
what i
are
in my perspective what they need to know
first of all
ngs they need to know the data
linux it's the work environment for
computational analysis uh programming in
our for instance it's our uh work tool
and pipelines are in bioinformatics
it's our
work picture where i can mix and match
several uh bioinformatics programs to
produce complex analytical workflows
okay
uh
i had some decisions
uh okay you you might ask well why you
you were teaching r instead of python
uh
for me
uh since the students are
only coming from biology background
i think are it's a little bit easier uh
to learn uh in like a 40 hour course 45
hour course okay and in terms of
pipelines for bioinformatics uh
the major goals where
students since the background with just
biology
they should be able to install and run
published pipelines and what happened uh
was that i was trying to teach them how
to uh
uh
program
in in next flow or snake made
but
the total lack of programming
skills uh
wasn't a nice experience so we have to
halt
these uh
thing
okay
so here i come with an example of the
richness of
how uh just simple
yes
dr papas we are running low on time do
you think you could wrap it up in the
next few minutes
thank you i'm just gonna skip this
and
and
for the research level bioinformatics uh
what happened
i i need
okay personalized mentoring okay
so
we work with uh several planchinomi uh
genomes
uh we published like this eucalyptus the
common being genome
and we are working now with brazilian
nutrient genome
but we also work uh in my group with
several other
species
uh with bacteria
fungi
with all lamix technologies and all
ngs technologies is the showcase and
it's very difficult to adapt to these
technical changes and
this poses both opportunities and
challenges
and challenges regarding bioinformatics
education and so
essentially uh
we have been developing
several pipelines
which
need several tools
individual tools so next flow darker
shiny are
and this is uh not trivial to
teach
in
in regular courses along the way
so
just to finish up
my experiences
in terms of gender imbalance
for
graduate and undergraduate as uh courses
absolutely no imbalance but for research
i still uh observe a gender imbalance
and let's not forget
that that the mother and father of
bioinformatics
is a day of margaret day off so
we should close this gap and just to
finish
uh
[Music]
the new biologists
need
several skills
and working fluency in in programming
statistics
and knowing the data but deep
and knowledge into the biology
is uh let's say what i consider the most
important thing
in the moment okay
with that i'm going to skip
the other
slides
and
[Music]
i will finish up
my
presentation here
with that okay
great thank you so much dr papas that
was a very awesome
no worries
okay so we have a few questions
for you
uh the first one is where do you think
bioinformatics is going next
this is a very interesting question
because
since
let's say i saw it the grain from the
beginning
and technology uh
simply uh is a
molding
is shaping biomathematics so
we started with okay we cannot have
genomes uh we cannot sequence dna then
we can sequence then we can sequence
short then we can sequence long and then
bioinformatic and this is a very
important point
bioinformatics
will change
next semester you see
we are tightly linked to uh uh
technological advances
biological uh new biological discoveries
and and bioinformatics is involved into
that so it's an ever-changing
field
it is
challenging but it's really nice
why
everybody needs bioinformaticians
everybody
great thank you so much
um i think we have time for one more
question
what are some bioinformatics careers
that are available in brazil
specifically
okay so
in brazil uh we have a huge problem
now
uh and unfortunately uh
career-wise and not for bioinformatics
uh brazil should be
an exception in the world it's not
because we are short in bioinformatics
careers we are short in science careers
because economic and political
difficulties uh and what
we're doing with bioinformatics all my
students
they are moving abroad
so
all my phd students are moving abroad
now one is
now in universal florida and the other
in
denmark
we cannot
what brazil doesn't have cannot absorb
and this is detrimental for future
development of the country
unfortunately
okay wolf again thank you so much and
that was an awesome presentation